it's the kind of wine that makes you
drunk before you realize it I don't
think I've ever had American champagne
my expectations are just like everything
else a more process the family-friendly
version of the drink fast and process
fast and process it just tastes like
alcohol bubbles and a little bit like
champagne I had some really nice one but
the complexity of the taste is not as
developed as it is with a European wines
and especially French I do have to say
it is a crime to drink champagne and
anything else that's not a flute to me
looks too bubbly you look like an apple
use of bubble right off the bat it
smells like white wine the color is is
pretty nice it's not too yellow too
sugary and it's not too clear like you
would hear it sparkling water Shelly's
over okay that's right someday that's it
yeah white wine white wine with levels
it's sweet it's bubbly it's you can feel
it in your tongue really sugary yeah I
mean I'd still drink it all right here
you go
remind me of shampoo me a little bit
show me that's exactly what we have yeah
for kids it's like apple juice with
bubbles but not a little bit like that
but you can tell there's a ball in here
it's not bad bad it's just it's just not
as good and I can feel the alcohol a
little bit more I think because it's not
as sweet as the previous one I would
rather have this with a meal but I'd
rather have the fruity one at a party
the texture is not as strong so it's
something that you can probably drink in
larger amounts instead of enjoy this is
not done on people though recommend the
second one the California champagne
because it is good but the first one
more for party it showed that there were
different options a bit more sweet some
of it would dry we wouldn't buy it we
would only drink it if given to us you
can find good ones good American
champagnes
you can't expect it to taste like French
Champagne